let me introduce myself i'm jim levinson
director of the jackson institute soon
to be the yale jackson school of global
affairs
i'd like to welcome everybody
a special welcome we're joined today by
a number of the ukrainian students here
at yale
uh our thoughts prayers
it's hard for me to imagine um
what you are going through as you are
here in new haven and dealing with the
situation at home
so um thank you for joining us
i'm joined also by two of my colleagues
up front here a number also in the
audience let me introduce them
rna vestad
professor of history
and global affairs rna
has written an amazing book
history of the cold war
and has written on and continues to
write on great power competition
i'm also joined by tim snyder
if you have walked by a bookstore turned
on the radio read a newspaper
uh watch television uh you know who tim
probably you probably know who tim is
we've had tv crews camped out
on the first floor of horchow hall now
for for quite some time
um tim has been working an incredible
schedule um very very grateful that he's
here
uh what you might not know um if you've
read you know only his most recent work
is that tim first really um you know his
earlier work as a hist as a historian
before he was a public intellectual
uh as well as historian was a book
called bloodlands
which
is a history of
exactly the area that we'll be talking
about today
in the post stalin era and i'm also
joined by met by nelly patlick
nellie is a graduate student uh here at
jackson uh she spent four years as a
peace corps volunteer in ukraine
and as we talked through things today i
thought it was important not just to
think about this from a historical and
geopolitical perspective but to also
keep our eye on the human perspective
and i hope
nellie might speak to that
the format today i want to start with
a question each to
rna to tim then to nelly
possible some follow-up and then q a
from you because i there's a lot of of
expertise and curiosity in the audience
today
i'll work my way down um
arnie let me start uh with you
you know
you've spent
much of your career thinking about great
power competition wasn't always called
that
does the current situation make sense to
you
from that perspective and
with that
sort of geopolitical perspective how
should we be thinking about this
so it depends obviously on whose
perspective you see this from jim i mean
i think in in in putin's own mind it
sort of makes sense i mean what he is
out to do
is to try to
resurrect some form of russian empire
never mind communism never mind the
soviet union i think looking
at this otherwise somewhat deranged
speech that he gave at the start of this
conflict you can actually understand
quite a bit of what putin thinks that he
is after and to him it is about not
recognizing
statehood but more importantly not
recognizing ukrainian nationhood right
uh and trying to
force ukrainians into this new russian
super state that he wants to set up so
this is a war of conquest
over kind that we really see certainly
towards the end of the 20th century
there are very few examples of this
um
you know you're working in in kuwait
perhaps so you try to take over someone
else's territory and make it your own
on your question whether it makes sense
in a broader uh perspective
and even from a russian perspective
beyond putin absolutely not i mean what
this will lead to is russia's isolation
it will create the russia that is even
more much more dependent on china
which is an angle i hope we can cover
here
then then what has been the case before
um
it will of course also lead to
uh tensions not just in europe but on on
a global scale
that we haven't seen for a very long
time because this war is in no way over
let me underline that i mean that is
really really important not just because
the ukrainians are fighting
for their for their country but also
because of the reactions that you've
seen elsewhere i mean how this has
brought
uh people first and foremost in europe
but also elsewhere together to a degree
that we simply haven't seen before and
if there is another
sort of piece of information that people
should look at
it is what happened in the german
bundestag this past week
which is a sea change in terms of how
germany is approaching its international
affairs coming from a social democratic
chancellor and from a green foreign
minister
so those are gonna i think gonna be the
effect so so for russia as a whole for
the international system makes no sense
whatsoever but in in putin's own
increasingly deranged mind you can see
what is going on
tim well
what do you think i was i was i want to
ask you sort of from the russian
perspective you know what
what's driving this
does it
makes sense um
and then i'd love to hear your reaction
to what harney said
[Music]
so first of all i i want to say i just
want to acknowledge the tremendous
cognitive inequality which this meeting
represents i wouldn't be here as a
historian of ukraine
if it weren't for historians of ukraine
who are now in ukraine
of course unable to practice their craft
because they are refugees or they're in
bunkers or they're in basements or
they're fighting the soldiers so if it
weren't for my ukrainian friends and
colleagues from whom i've learned that
weren't for their books if it weren't
for their language i wouldn't be in a
position i wouldn't have a job at yale i
wouldn't be sitting here talking to you
so i just i want to acknowledge that
before i say anything else
um and jim i hope we have a second
round of questions before we go to the
audience because i want to hear you ask
arnie specifically about china before
before we before we do anything else
that seems to be incredibly important
um so you ask about the russian
perspective and um
as i'm as i'm sure you know
one of the interesting things about this
war is that
there isn't a russian
perspective um there isn't even
the kind of artificial euphoria
which was generated back in 2014.
so as all of you know and many of you
will intimately remember because i i see
people who wrote about it and and were
there
in 2014 russia invaded ukraine the first
time in 2014 russia managed to occupy
the next crimea
and attempted with special forces to um
to provoke rebellions in eight of the
ukrainian districts aid of the ukrainian
oblasts with partial success in two of
them and that partial success had to do
with the successful provocation of an
artillery war in and around the city of
donetsk in 2014.
so
i just remind you of that because i'm
trying to i'm trying to set up a certain
contrast
back then there was a russian propaganda
buildup to the war so in 2013 um there
was a there was a sequence of propaganda
targeted for specific audiences um
people on the right were told that
ukraine was uh was gay and cosmopolitan
and people on the far right were told
that ukraine was nazi and people on the
far left were told that ukraine was
sorry if i got it confused people on the
far left were told that people that
ukraine was nazi there was a very
coordinated campaign which went on and
russia basically won that information
war but more but but but also the
russian public
was prepared for something to happen in
ukraine and then when it did happen when
crimea was seized there was this moment
of euphoria glorious speech in the
russian parliament you know
parliamentarians in tears you know all
that sort of thing
that we don't have this time around um
there wasn't really a propaganda
preparation you know for for this war in
in russia um
putin's given a series of speeches in
which he seems almost defensive about
what he is doing
um you know he's even used the phrase
like it might seem hard for you to
understand you know so when you get to
that point as a dictator you know when
you're you're almost you know you're in
this didactic or even hectoring mode
with your own people
that's something different than being in
the charismatic mode where everyone is
going along with you and carrying you
and carrying you along so um you know
not to pick on the question jim but i
just i think it's important to note that
that putin the relationship between
putin and his own people is quite
different than it was eight years ago we
don't know exactly what that means yet
but we do know a couple of things one of
them is that
right from the beginning there were
there were peace protests in russia
and every piece everyone who protests
for peace in russia knows that he or she
is going to be arrested almost
immediately so the people who actually
protest presumably represent a very
small percentage of the people who
sensed that something was wrong and the
sensing that something is wrong is very
important in itself because as as you
all know the the infra information is
controlled in russia very effectively so
the propaganda might not be working but
the kind of knowledge that we take for
granted you know on this campus and in
much of the world that that kind of
knowledge is not easily available in
russia so people who protested right
away were people who knew just knew that
something was off that something was
wrong that this war should not should
not be should not be happening the
second thing that we know
is that this this decision was taken by
a very small group of people um i mean
by one man of course but i think it was
only known to a very small group of
people which means that even the russian
elite has not really had a chance to
adjust to this or to find a way to
rationalize it or to make plans for
their own future under this regime of
sanctions which has which has now
followed so so russian points of view
are much more plural
than they were than they were eight
years ago um and then if but if the
question is about
how it makes sense to to to mr putin i
think um arnavestad has already signaled
some important things it it depends
all of this depends
on the assumption that there isn't
really a ukrainian nation and there
isn't really a ukrainian state i mean
it's
i mean arnie may have another idea but i
mean as far as i can read it the end the
initial operational plan assumed that
the government would quickly collapse
and its members could be captured and
killed along with the entire ukrainian
intellectual and civic and political
elite the idea was that you know
ukraine's not really a nation there's
just a thin upper crust of educated
people who have been somehow
artificially westernized so as soon as
the tanks roll in they'll try to run
we'll capture them we'll kill them and
then the ukrainians are kind of in poet
mass their kind of undefined group their
pre-colonial tribe they'll just listen
to the stronger right that i think is
the governing assumption that's a very
familiar governing assumption i mean to
any of those of you who have studied
imperial history or colonial history
you'll recognize that assumption
that the colonial power says the other
state is not really a state the colonial
power says the other nation is not
really
a nation right and it's interesting to
see people in the po you know in the
post-colonial world like the kenyan
ambassador for example for instance to
the u.n immediately recognize those
those patterns um
but that is the fundamental assumption
and it it runs you know and as a
historian
it always kind of pains me to even
contest ideas like this because they're
not historical ideas like much as putin
pretends to talk about history these
ideas don't come from history they come
from colonial reflexes basically but
so but i i have to contest them i just
have to make the point out the basic
problem
which is that you know no nation and no
state is perfect but the ukrainian
nation and the ukrainian state are
social and political realities insofar
as there are social and political
realities in the world those things are
not really contestable and historically
speaking
what's odd is that
you don't even need to get to
maidan 2014 or invasion 2022 to talk
about the ukrainian nation i mean it's
true those things have consolidated the
ukrainian nation or they've
they've put the ukrainian nation before
our eyes and given us an opportunity to
examine it but um but the but the idea
that there's a ukrainian nation is just
much older
than that um i mean the the the modern
ukrainian national movement goes back
200 years and before that they're
actually pre-modern elements of
ukrainian nation far before there are
actually elements of such a nation and
many other places i mean not to make the
point you know too strongly but the
history of ukraine is much older than
the history of the united states of
america however however you wish to
calculate it
um
and so you know just looking at it more
practically
when the soviet union was founded
um it was founded in the form it was
because people acknowledged there was a
ukraine now the so-called russian civil
war between you know let's say 1917 and
1921 which was a very complicated affair
involving you know people supporting a
russian empire's revival people
supporting ukraine people supporting a
russian revolution
that civil war was largely fought in
ukraine
and it was fought by a number of
important people some of you know some
of the politics politics was led by
someone called stalin and those people
recognized at the time
that there was a ukraine they knew they
were fighting against ukrainian armies
right at the time 100 years ago and the
soviet union was formed as a union of
republics
as opposed to some kind of you know
homogeneous revolutionary unit because
everyone knew at the time there was a
ukraine if you if you look at the
writings you know i'll just like
randomly pick some sources but if you
look at league of nations reports or if
you look at the writings of josef waltz
or like whatever cultural or literary or
statistical analysis you you kind of
prefer from the 1920s ukraine as a
category was widely known to everyone
it wasn't some surprising thing right
and so its existence with i'm not going
to do all of soviet history here i'm
just trying to make the point that its
existence was already widely
acknowledged a hundred years ago and the
fact that you would have to fight to get
control of it and that this was
dangerous this was known to the
bolsheviks it was known to lenin and
stalin and of course it was also known
to a later generation of soviet rulers
such as khrushchev who was sent to
pacify western ukraine at the end of the
second world war the insurgency and
counterinsurgency in western ukraine
after the second world war required
hundreds of thousands of deaths and
hundreds of thousands of sentences to
the gulag for it to be brought down so
those are things that like base that
students of history would know and what
mr putin has succeeded in doing
is forgetting soviet history right arnie
referred to a kind of western a kind of
russian empire i mean the kind of
russian empire he has in mind is a kind
of mishmash of all of the things that he
likes from history but what he succeeded
in driving away is actual soviet history
and the rec at least the practical
recognition that there was such a thing
as the ukrainian nation which at a
certain time everybody knew what he's
managed to do is to take a kind of
extreme version
of the 1970s when he was formed a time
of russification in the soviet union and
then as he's aged in the last decade
especially he's taken on elements of
extreme right russian nationalism and
pushed these to this kind of logical
conclusion which he now seems to have
settled on that there's no ukrainian
nation and no ukrainian state
and of course that's that's not true um
and now that it's been proved not to be
true it seems like he has no choice but
to try to you know double down as one
does when one is a tyrant and then that
leads to the the consequences that arne
was was speaking about
thank you tim nelly what are you hearing
from your friends and colleagues
yeah um so just sort of to add a little
bit about my background since i think uh
most of you know uh these two professors
here um so i was in ukraine for for four
years as jim said for the first two
years as a peace corps volunteer in a
small town in south central ukraine
where i had the opportunity to meet
alexei five years ago at a camp
and then i decided to stay and i started
working for education usa which is a
network of the state department that
promotes
u.s higher education opportunities and
so
during that time for about a year and a
half i was doing outreach and i had the
immense opportunity to travel to 21 out
of 24 regions of ukraine and really see
the diversity of the country
can you hear me okay
yes okay good
so i think
you know as a peace corps volunteer i
was in a town of 15 000 people
i was there was another american there
but he was working on different projects
in a different part of part of the city
so
really i was you know there was nothing
special about my position there i was
integrating into the community learning
the language
treated just as any other teacher i was
an english teacher at a high school um
so i was at all the staff meetings and
and everything like that you know i
wasn't treated any differently as as an
american and so um
one thing that i really want to
highlight is the generosity of the
ukrainian people it's hard to even talk
about
it's going to be a long hour guys sorry
in our training when they were sort of
preparing us to culturally adapt to
ukrainian life they talked to us about
how ukrainians have an outer circle in
an inner circle and the outer circle can
be really hard to
get through
because ukrainians and other slavic
people don't smile at you on the street
you know like we do in america and so it
might seem that they're very cold
but we were told once you get into that
inner circle
there's nothing else like it and you're
treated like family and i found that to
be incredibly true
and it was a generosity that
i really struggled to understand and
even to accept um
i just didn't i couldn't really
comprehend how people could be so
generous to someone that they didn't
even know especially after all of
the horrors that they have been through
in their history as i'm sure professor
snyder will will talk about i just
couldn't believe that they would be so
welcoming to a stranger because
ukrainians are the type of people who
give you everything they have even when
they have nothing left um
and i think we're seeing that right now
so i would just say sort of from the
human perspective um
i'm really really glad that the world is
seeing right now the generosity
and the love and the fierceness to
resist of the ukrainian people and
putin truly truly messed with the wrong
people
and i think i think we're all seeing
that
and in terms of sort of what i'm hearing
and seeing
peace corps volunteers ukraine was the
biggest peace corps country for many
many years so peace returned peace corps
volunteers are now mobilizing there's a
network of about 1100 of us right now
working to
help of course friends and family that
we still have there arrange humanitarian
aid things like that
but so much of that is already of course
already happening in ukraine i'm in
touch with my community there and
i got um
a message from a friend of mine there
about two days ago and she said you know
in all the chaos and everything people
are abandoning their pets is there any
way that you can help out give it get us
some fun so we can be buying food and
shelters for these animals um and so
that's
what people there are thinking about
right now they're mobilizing um to help
people out you know they're settling um
idps in my town right now even though
they themselves are are at war they're
doing everything they can to help people
have fled from other parts of the
country so i think that's just what i
want to highlight is the generosity and
and the love and i'm just really glad
that
the rest of the world is seeing um the
spirit of of ukrainians right now
thank you
arnie i want to follow up a little bit
on a couple things you said um
there was mention of
this leading to a russia
that is more dependent on china
you also spoke i think the phrase was
tensions in europe
um
be great if you could follow up on both
of those
in terms of tensions in europe
my read is that this has brought europe
more together
um which i don't
so i was puzzled by the use of of the
phrase tensions maybe you could uh
say a little bit about that and then
moving forward with the russia more
dependent on china
how does that change
sort of how we we think about the the
global balance of power such that it is
so let me talk about the china angle to
this first because it is really really
important
and we don't know yet
exactly how it is going to play out
what's happening right at the moment is
that the chinese leaders are getting
increasingly embarrassed as they should
be
with the behavior of their close partner
in in
trying to destroy ukraine
what we need to do is to push
even harder than what we have done
in order to increase that
sense of
embarrassment of of being
hurt both directly and indirectly by
what their partners are doing
um it's interesting that that was not
the initial chinese reaction i mean the
initial chinese reaction was very
clearly um that this was something that
would work
to china's advantage if the chinese
leaders were able to sit very still and
do very little and then the
the reactions the international
reactions against russia's behavior
would force russia even more closely to
china to put it bluntly to be exploited
more efficiently
by china the way russia is already today
one of the big
issues that you should tell all of your
russian friends if you haven't
is that putin's strategy has led to an
almost complete loss of russian
sovereignty with regard to china who was
taking advantage of this even before the
invasion and attempted occupation of
ukraine took place but now seem to be
having
an even better opportunity the problem
however for the chinese leadership is
that what we see now over television
screens of the behavior that russian
troops are showing in ukraine
goes against so much of what they
themselves have tried to propagate to
the world
of chinese aims ever since the people's
republic of china was set up in 1949 on
the principles of sovereignty
territorial integrity non-intervention
you know which the chinese have been
going on about for a very long time so
these are the buttons that we should try
to hit and i've been trying to hit as
well with the with the chinese when i
speak to to people and news outlets in
china about this
um
and i think that sense that this is
problematic including to ex to explain
to their own people
uh what is going on is now increasing
uh in china it was very interesting to
see today that they're also starting to
prepare for for an economic backlash the
asian infrastructure investment bank
uh which is in my view entirely
dominated by china has now stopped
issuing loans to russia and the reason
why they've done that is not because the
chinese are moving away from the
russians diplomatically but because of
the fear of the effect of u.s and
western secondary sanctions which could
hit that bank will hit that bank uh if
they continue their current lending
activities so these are the kinds of
things that we that we ought to we ought
to think about i think
it is important in the kind of situation
that we have now to continue to speak to
the chinese about this um even though
the answers we get are not the the
answers that we would we would like to
have but china is going to be important
with regard to this
i also think speaking of the popular
level i think about ordinary people in
china in spite of the heavily censored
chinese media there is an increasing
concern about what is happening i was
going to ask you about that because i
know you stay in touch with colleagues
there speak the language i think there
is absolutely no doubt about that um
and it is interesting it's interesting
particularly over the last
three to four days to see how that has
increased and that's obviously also
something by you know by publishing in
chinese because chinese are smart people
they find their way around the the
great firewall that the
regime has set up to prevent them from
getting information so so we should do
more on that just quickly jim on on
europe
so when i use the term tension i meant
first and foremost in in terms of the
relationship between russia and the rest
of europe
um that's where
um you know for a very long time very
clearly there is going to be
um uh increased tension it's true that
this has brought europe together to a
remarkable degree but the question still
remains and we have to be able to ask
ourselves these tough questions
what should europe which is really at
the front line of this conflict do you
know with regard to the fighting that
goes on at the moment and on that as
well there are
different answers i am really struck by
the degree to which uh european neutrals
like finland and sweden have been
willing to try to support ukraine
militarily in a way that again only a
few weeks ago no one would have dreamt
about
being possible
and and resupplying them with weapons
that they actually need because these
are the kinds of weapons that they have
developed for their own defense
obviously thinking ahead about about
russia i think that's hugely important
because it's going to spill over to
other european countries as well in
what to me is the crucial willingness
to
to resupply ukrainians who are fighting
for their lives against this invasion i
want to underline that so there are
there are some people in europe and
there's some people here who are saying
we have to be careful with this because
we do not want to unleash the third
world war
now with regard to resupplying the
ukrainians
on the ground with the kind of weapons
that they actually need at the moment
that is not risking a third world war
that is making the risk of a third world
war
significantly lower than what it would
have been not doing that because it's
only if uh putin's regime realizes that
they they get the kind of resistance
that we are now seeing in ukraine that
it will be possible to push back in
later cases as well if we don't do that
the situation would be much more
dangerous so i think it's it is
important to underline that aspect of it
as well i was offered uh in a
pre-arranged visit up at west point
yesterday and spoke to spoke to people
there about it and
as many of you will know military people
tend to be the most reluctant that we
have to to think about actually getting
involved in foreign conflict but i
wanted to get across to them that you
know resupplying ukraine uh in any way
that we can is actually for the in
strategic sense for the good of this
country and for the good of you
tim do you want to
add anything to that
i just i wanted to say um that i very
much appreciated nellie's nellie's
remarks about her time in in ukraine
um it's you know in in so far as we
insofar as we have anything to say you
know it's because we've at some point
had someone to talk to and someone
someone to learn from so i very much
appreciated that
i'll just i'll just add a maybe a couple
brief words about about about europe um
and about russia
what i wanted i mean
going back to
um
your initial question jim one thing that
i wanted to say which i forgot to say is
that
even in the soviet union
ukraine was governed as ukraine
so he was governed it was governed at
times with horrible repressiveness as
for example during the first five-year
plan
which led to
political decisions in moscow
to allow about four million ukrainians
to die in a famine who did not have to
die
um
and that by the way
goes to the question another way because
when you ask you know what what is putin
thinking
um
he's thinking that none of that is true
you know whereas
for for ukrainians
uh you know regardless of whether the
lodomar comes up in political
conversations or not it's a lived family
reality it's a matter of you know
grandparents great-grandparents people
know it's true whether you talk about it
or not whether it comes up in
international politics or not
and that you know that interpretation
of of the stalin years is one of the
things which marks off ukrainians from
from russians you know people when it
comes to identity everybody wants to
make like these quick jumps like it
should be about language and you know
that's like a shortcut and it's
completely wrong and i wish people
wouldn't do it you know i mean arne
speaks mandarin but that doesn't you
know
though i have had people team in china
asking me which part of china was from
but
that's good stop now i think that's good
that's that's that's as good as it gets
with languages when people like know
they think you're from their country but
they're not sure which part that's
that's about as good as it gets
but you see my point i mean we're all
we're all speaking english here but i
mean there may not be anybody in this
room who's from the united kingdom and
if you know
and if you are you're probably too shy
to say so um
so but but so but people want there to
be a shortcut they want to say like i
want to be able to say who you are
because of how you look or you know what
you say but identity is actually about
experience about you know that
biographical experience your own
experience experience of your family the
experience that you think you understand
and
the experiences of ukrainians you know
not just in the last decade not just in
the last few days you know but in the
last few years with maidan
in the last 30 years with a generation
of people who have grown up
in what is
a
admittedly a cr sometimes cranky and
ramshackle and unpredictable but
nevertheless independent state you know
people who are few people who are you
know 45 and under now have have have had
the dominant experiences of their life
in an independent ukraine but it goes
back much further than that
it goes back the differences go back
hundreds of years and i won't bore you
with them um because that's what i work
on and you should always know that what
you yourself work on is going to be
boring to an audience so i won't dwell
on it but the the the point though the
point though is that when people when
you want to see the difference between
russians and ukrainians it's often like
it's a matter of experience and uh and
the stalin period
is something that
what putin is trying to literally like
write it out and flatten it out i don't
know how many of you
pay attention to these memory laws but
there's a law in russia which says that
you're not allowed to speak about the
period 1939 to 1941. you're quite and
then right before the invasion that the
criminal penalties on that particular
law
were strengthened
um and not accidentally because putin's
behavior
is very much like stalin's behavior in
1939 he's going he's going west he's
claiming that it's to rescue endangered
compatriots he's claiming that he's
doing it because the state to his
immediate west no longer really exists
or doesn't exist um that's pretty much
exactly what stalin said in 1939 when
the soviet union invaded invaded poland
um but my deeper point here is that
the the the what the russian leadership
is doing is flattening out a history
which is
central to the memory the lived memory
not the political memory of of people in
in ukraine
um
and uh and and and so that's that's one
thing that i wanted to get to that there
is this soviet there's this soviet
experience which was very different for
ukrainians and for russians and as
remembered as such but that even in the
soviet union
no one was denying that there was a
ukraine like it was governed as it was
governed as a ukraine and that's what as
arne was saying that's what makes this
proposal to govern ukraine as russia
so radical
that's never been done
ever the russian empire was not a
russian national state it didn't operate
according to national principles the
people who governed it not to put too
fine a point on it were not russians it
would the elite in the russian empire
was not ethnically russian for the most
part um he was oh you look surprised it
was german and swedish you know it was
polish um you know when when the russian
empire took took over kiev in the late
17th century that was the that was the
only
institution of higher education that
they had so i mean there were no public
there was no publishing there was no
university in russia at the time but so
what i'm trying to say is that like this
notion of russia governing ukraine as
russia is entirely anachronistic and
novel it's never happened before and so
putin like reaching back and talking
about a thousand years and all this
total nonsense russia wasn't a modern
nation then right
the russian empire controlled much of
what is now ukraine but it wasn't
governing it as a national state the
soviet union controlled what is now
ukraine but it wasn't governing it as a
national state the idea that a russian
russian on russia on ethnic principles
can dominate ukraine is a really radical
idea it's the most radical version of
how to govern ukraine that's ever been
around except for the nazi one and it's
coming at a point in history where the
ukrainian nation has been most most
fully formed so i just i wanted to bring
that particular point like that to it to
into it to a sharp point thanks
one last question it's not a very fair
one before we open it up
um you know arne you said it's important
to realize this is not close to being
over
um it's an important point
i'm wondering if either
you or tim would be willing to hazard a
guesstimate a prediction
as to how this i don't want to say ends
because it will be ongoing but how this
plays out over the next six to 12 months
i think goes to you first
[Laughter]
and as i said i know it's not a fair
question um
well you also get a slightly unfair
answer to it jim it won't end until the
russian troops have withdrawn from
ukraine i mean that's the that's the key
element that it's important to recognize
now i mean
the idea that it's possible to get any
kind of settlement that will lead to
any form of stability even the kind of
stability that putin wants to impose
in ukraine without a withdrawal of
russian troops is unimaginable and we
are seeing that now every day on the
streets of ukrainian cities
the big question is of course how long
it will take before
the russians in charge realize that that
is the case and and the only answer i
have to that is that that depends on the
degree of pressure not just the the
pressure they get by
a lot of of young russian people coming
back to russia and coffins to put it
bluntly but also the kind of pressure
that we can put
on russia so
uh
as people appear now i've worked
very closely with uh with colleagues in
in russia for for quite some time
as a historian because parts of my
interest have been connected to
to soviet history
and of course i tried to make use of
that opportunity to contact people
while as i was saying to tim the other
day while i was resigning from the
various boards and
committees and various other things that
i found myself on in russia uh also to
to to contact uh uh friends and and
colleagues and acquaintances directly
and and
tell them why i've done that but also
what i think the consequences for russia
will be or or what they have now done so
i think i think that's in a way the
the the
the
the timeline here so this is also why
china is important right
let me just comment on that very briefly
if i can jim again because
you know this is the first global crisis
where i think that china potentially has
more influence than this country
and so what iron others are trying to
tell
our chinese friends is that with great
power comes great responsibility you
can't simply sit back and do nothing and
hope that the whole thing will blow over
in a way that will serve you you can't
do it for domestic reasons and you can't
do it for international reasons
and here some parallels imprecise as
they might be from history
but concerning as they as they as they
are need to be put to them so one of the
perspectives that i now put to my
chinese friends is
the parallel which i've been discussing
in other contexts with the kind of
global situation that we see now and the
situation in europe at the end of the
19th to the beginning of the 20th
century right
where you had this tremendous growth
in in german power germany had just been
reunified it was industrializing it was
at the forefront of technology it was
obviously
moving towards aiming towards a dominant
position in europe
right next to germany was a
ancient but rather decrepit empire
austria-hungary which had problems with
a lot of nationalities inside the empire
but also along its borders right
and for reasons that were uh were
strategic in a very limited sense
germany increasingly became a close ally
of that uh empire even if the germans
knew that this would lead to trouble
this you know there would be
difficulties coming out of that
um they couldn't foresee what happened
in the summer of 1914 but there clearly
were difficulties this is an imprecise
but still rather instructive parallel to
the relationship between china and
russia today and it should really be
a memento for the for the chinese
leaders to think about this that they
could end up in a kind of situation
because of what the russians are doing
that would
really move china away from the path
that it's on now to even within its own
region towards further further influence
for for for reasons that are not
primarily of chinese doing because
they're sitting back on this but because
of their pseudo alliance with the
russians
tim do you want to yeah let me
let me have a crack at that from from a
different from a different angle um i
mean i i from a great distance um
i'm also struck by this sort of triangle
of
of us china russia where
the it's the chinese it seems to me
could turn this off
in a heartbeat if they wanted to
but their first reaction is to put the
responsibility on us and we actually
have much less ability to do anything
about it one way or another there's
something very striking about about that
juxtaposition but on how this comes to
an end i just want to stress one
dimension of it
which we haven't really talked about um
which is the dimension of of unreality
the dimension of propaganda or
information the dimension of how people
think about all of this
because
well of course you know the war the war
in ukraine is very real and you know
people people are people are killing and
dying now you know
and living i mean um a treasured
colleague an incredible person just got
married um in her bulletproof vest
before this thing started
nevertheless it's also very important
to ask
whether reality you know i'm very
old-fashioned about these things i
believe in facts and truth and so on um
whether whether reality defends itself
against unreality
because what's been characteristic of
21st century war in russia
has been that the informational
character has run out way ahead of the
kinetic character so they've done much
better in the war for mines than they've
done in the war for territory in general
and um and this is a reflection of an
interesting turn that was taken in
russian politics and society in the
early 21st century um peter pomeranza
has a really good book about this
called nothing is true and everything is
possible where you know once when
certain conditions prevail
extreme inequality of wealth
centralization of media you know major
oligarchical clan is in charge of the
state
you can you can govern not by promising
people
policy based on facts that changes the
future but you can govern by having the
best spectacle
and by crowding out other spectacles or
other sources of information and so
russia then has been fighting wars that
way and the war in 2014 against ukraine
was a success in that way it wasn't
actually a battlefield success
particularly it went less well for them
than they expected on the battlefield
but they did a very good job with
western public opinion and they did a
very good job with american public
opinion um they managed to prevent
american and european elites from seeing
the basic things that were happening
right it's still hard people still feel
a kind of internal resistance to saying
russia invaded ukraine in 2014 although
that's the most you know that's the
simplest most lapidary most accurate
characterization of what of what
happened um there are all kinds of
pre-programmed reflexes that people have
instead of that even though that's you
know that's the most important thing
that happened for this war it has gone
less well for russia people learned a
lot in the last eight years um
uh ukrainians learned a lot um it's it's
it's it's the ukrainians have done a
very good job at expressing themselves
as themselves
so not trying to take up the cudgels and
fight a russian-style information war
but rather do creative interesting
things you know to just to make it clear
that they're real and they have a
character even their propaganda directed
against the russians is often very
interesting or even has a kind of
almost humanitarian
tone to it so the ukrainians have done a
better job but the larger the larger
issue here is um reality you know
can we talk to russians and just help
them understand what's going on without
browbeating them you know can we can we
get to our russian friends and
colleagues or their colleagues or our
russian cousins and their cousins and
just communicate a little bit
is the west going to do a better job at
talking about what's actually going on
which doesn't mean making better
propaganda i don't think we win with
better propaganda i don't think you know
i don't think that's really our job but
can reality as such hold back unreality
that's a big so if this thing only comes
to a close
if we continue to get keep a grip on
what's actually happening on the
battlefield that's a big part of it if
we drift off into propaganda
stereotypes or wishful thinking you know
or we spend our time talking about the
concepts that mr putin wants us to talk
about you know then then this goes on
right so i just i i think it can i mean
i want to dodge the question jim i do
think this can end i mean i can imagine
an arrangement whereby this would end
but like everything else it depends like
you know like everything else like this
conversation itself it depends upon the
ukrainians continuing to fight right i
mean imagine imagine a world in which
the ukrainians hadn't fought it's a very
different world right but if the
ukrainians hadn't fought
we would not be thinking about all the
things we're thinking right now right if
the ukrainians hadn't fought that
wouldn't make putin a better dictator or
the russian system a better system we
just wouldn't be thinking about it in
the same way if the ukrainians hadn't
fought you know people around the world
wouldn't have had a chance to think
about what they you know to think about
what colonization and decolonization
mean or to think about what democracy
and oligarchy mean right they've given
they've given us this chance including
the chance to have the conversation that
we're that we're having right now but
for there to be some kind of a
settlement i mean there's there are the
arnie's already mentioned all the parts
the ukrainians have to keep fighting
people have to keep helping them there
has to be a conversation if that's the
word among russian elites um there has
to be resistance on the part of the
russian population and big powers like
china and america have to keep nudging
and suggesting possible ways out
can
so i just wanted to add that even after
so i've been in the prediction business
for a couple years so i won't speak to
speak to that part but um
even after the russian troops withdraw
from ukraine
this will not be over for ukrainians for
a very very long time
so
i'm so glad to see so many people here
today we maxed out the attendance and so
i want to
ask you to resist the urge to disengage
because even in a week i've seen a big
difference in the way i have the new
york times sort of live stream updates
on my computer and i've seen a big
difference in the way that they're
covering things even when even within a
week
and i also forgot to mention as part of
my background i've been working with the
state department for about nine months
now tracking russian disinformation
efforts and synthesizing those for
government partners so i have some
background there and can speak to that
and can say that they're actively
right now pushing narratives and pushing
efforts to try to get western allies to
disengage from this issue so just
something to keep in mind as this goes
on
that's true for so many tragedies and
conflicts that
happen around the world
it inevitably happens but you know
there's been a hot war raging in eastern
ukraine for eight years and the west
disengaged from it
really stopped covering it and it's part
of the reason that we're here today so
just something to to keep in mind nelly
thanks
i'd like to open it up with the
remaining time for a few questions
um
jimmy
a veteran and i hatch
in a bunch of different conflicts in the
past in our history and this reminds me
particularly of the former yugoslavia
and while i'm not culturally aware of
the ukrainians
their history
i do think that there's the opportunity
for what happened in the form of
yugoslavia when um
the people who did the bad things there
who created the mass graves they they
concentrated everybody's attention on
sarajevo and during that time they were
doing things in the other part of the
country and i'm worried that that for
example this morning when i saw the news
about the nuclear plant being
shelled
what do they not want us to see and what
do you think
how do you think that they'll
keep our attention focused and do
something in a different part of the
country what do we need to be looking
for there
thank you
are we doing this one by one
no i think that's a very
apt observation i mean the the russians
are not on their on their best game with
the propaganda and the provocation yet
because i believe
their understand their their their
expectation was that ukraine was going
to fold within 24 hours um and that we
we think that not just because of how of
how they um set up quote unquote the the
first stage of the operation but also
because of some things that were
accidentally published in the russian
press
which basically they accidentally
published some of their victory
declarations which if you haven't seen
them are absolutely
chilling
because they basically speak of a of
what you know what rafael lim can
call the genocide in which
the the nation has been decapitated and
everyone else just has no choice but to
go along and ukraine has essentially
ceased to cease to exist um
so
uh
they're not on they're not
in terms of provocation and ideology and
disinformation i think it's only going
to get stronger as i think maybe nelly
was suggesting
as they try to because they went in
doing one thing that didn't work and now
they're still i think trying to figure
out how they're going to talk about what
they're doing and whether it's hard for
them to talk about it because they're
not really sure themselves it's it's
putin doubling down and they have to win
but what winning means
they don't know and of course i agree
with arne like it's gonna be
i don't think they're gonna win ever but
you know the question is whether the
question is whether there's some kind of
acceptable solution in months
you know or whether or whether it's like
afghanistan plus for them in in in years
and hor for in horror for the ukrainians
uh but i mean what
what i think is real
is the attempt to assassinate the
ukrainian leadership and that's
something which is
difficult to keep your eye on
but i think important not to forget
about and i don't think the russians
have forgotten about it
that that this war was about
decapitation um announced as such pretty
much pretty explicitly we should
probably you know probably remember that
and if ukrainian leaders you know
disappear or whatever it might be
there's a pretty strong presumption
about about what might what is in fact
happening you know and that i mean
that putin's concept is that ukraine
doesn't exist there are just a few
thousand you know artificial
what like that when those people start
disappearing you know we can i mean this
is a horrible thing to say but
that plan has already has essentially
been announced
please
and do you need the microphone so that
uh the live the
streaming can catch it
um first i want to say thank you to the
panelists and everyone for coming out
it's been
really instructive and eye-opening to
kind of hear your perspectives i'm very
appreciative um it's just like a passive
american observer of what's going on
um
i i have seen sort of several narratives
uh put forth in the last week that
perhaps
some of what is motivating russia right
now to kind of get in themselves into
this mess
beyond just sort of the ideological
state defining um
stuff is is actually like sort of maybe
also a battle over resources
specifically oil and natural gas um with
the the natural gas found in the black
sea
uh just prior to the 2014
invasion um which russia controlled
crimea now that that would be the the
main way that ukraine could have
exploited those natural gas resources um
but then there's still some that are
available from odessa and other ports
that ukraine still controls in the black
sea
um and i was and i guess so if ukraine
were to exploit these natural gas
resources and become the new eastern
european petrol state
um which theoretically could threaten
the russian economy which is primarily
based on the exploitation of
fossil fuels and the sale of them to the
european continent
i was just wondering if you
experts think there's any validity to
that theory or if it's sort of maybe
sideshow distraction or
yeah just anything you might speak about
that sort of energy and resource side of
things thank you
so i don't think that's
one of the key reasons why putin has
acted the way he has
we know again from some of these leaked
documents that tim referred to
that
in part of how this is being presented
was supposed to be presented after
victory
from the russian side then the idea was
that this would strengthen this new
cohesion that had been created around
russia economically also with regard to
access to resources which then in
putin's telling the west was trying to
cut off in order to strangle russia i
mean entire nonsense of course with
regard to it
but so i don't think that's what we
should be looking at most closely i
think the the as tim has been saying the
central idea here
is about the attempted destruction of
ukrainian nationhood
and that is a story that is first and
foremost putin's story about russia
and about the kind of russia that he
wants to see projected into the future
um
and this is where some of the dissonance
comes up as well i mean i i do think
that is actually quite quite important
to note here and i i really appreciated
what tim said about
this being a very novel way of thinking
about how to rule how to rule ukraine i
hadn't given enough talk to that and i
think that's a really really good point
but it also is a way of thinking that it
seems to me is out of whack with almost
everything that is happening elsewhere
in the world
and getting back to the chinese and
asian side this is the kind of thing
that
i think is really difficult for their
elites to get their heads around i mean
they don't like us very much necessarily
they don't like the the way the united
states is is governed or the way europe
is governed or anything of that sort but
there is still a in terms of
conversations and in terms of
discussions
some of my chinese friends like to say
we do speak the same language right
in terms of the things that matter and
the things that matter less
in terms of putin's russian elite that
is not the case i mean there is a there
is a kind of of
of discourse that seemed to be entirely
internal
uh
to that particular elite and
on the issue of resources you know i i
think in most other settings
for with this kind of effort being put
into taking over another country that
would have ranked fairly highly up you
know on the agenda
it doesn't in the russian case uh and
the reason for that is that the
discourse is different
right from from what you find in many
other settings at least that would be my
response to
[Music]
yeah i mean
america and russia are very are very
different but if you think back to the
u.s invasion of iraq in 2003 anybody
looking at the distance would have said
oh yeah isn't that about the oil fields
but somehow it wasn't even about the oil
fields right it was about views about
the world and how the world was going to
change after a war and so on which which
were which were entirely wrong you know
just as these ideas are entirely wrong
um
i i just wanted to i wanted to i agree
complete with what arnold said i wanted
though to tack onto your question a kind
of larger observation which is that
the 21st century is a century of
hydrocarbon oligarchy and
getting to the 22nd century is going to
be a matter of breaking up hydrocarbon
oligarchy foreign and domestic and this
entire war wouldn't be possible without
the way that the russian state is
constructed
as a hydrocarbon oligarchy and you know
i mean of course day to day month to
month what we need to be thinking about
are the ukrainians and supplying the
ukrainians but this is this whole war is
actually one more piece of evidence that
we need to shift to
clean and safe sources of energy um
that's so this is this isn't a
distraction i mean we shouldn't be
thinking of this as a distraction from
climate change this would be like one
more reason why we need to be shifting
over to different sources of energy
so i'm mindful of the time and i'm
mindful of the fact that we're holding
this at a
day and time where classes actually are
in session
uh so with some regret i'm gonna call it
to a close
uh we could talk for a long long time
and as uh nelly said i hope i hope we
will be
uh i'd like to thank the panelists uh
for their time this morning and most of
all i'd like to thank all of you uh for
taking time out of your day
showing the concern um that's evidenced
by your
being here on a friday morning
thank you so much
[Music]
you